Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
油砂开采为加拿大的碳排放作出了巨大贡献。因此，六家最大的公司联合起来，在迈向“净零”的道路上大步迈进。投资于技术和创新。每桶平均碳排放量已经削减了22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位。正在建设全球最大的碳捕集与封存设施之一。我们的“净零”计划正在推进中，并且我们在多个途径上都取得了进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 查看我们的行动计划。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The evening of Monday, April 9, 1962 in Oceanside, California. He pressed a fingertip to the phone's rotary dial and turned its wheel until it hit the stop position. He repeated this motion over and over until he had spun each digit of the Oceanside Police Department's phone number. I am going to pull something here in Oceanside, he warned the answering officer. And you will never be able to figure it out.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得自己需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序上或我们网站上的本期节目简介。1962年4月9日星期一傍晚，地点加利福尼亚州欧申赛德。他用指尖按住电话的转盘，一路转动转盘直到它碰到阻挡位置。他一遍又一遍地重复这个动作，直到拨完欧申赛德警察局电话号码的每一位数字。“我打算在欧申赛德搞点事情，”他向接线警员警告道，“而且你们永远也查不出来。”
The following night, 29-year-old Oceanside cab driver Ray Davis pulled up at a downtown taxi stand on Mission Avenue. At 11.10, a customer approached his vehicle and climbed into the back seat. Ray radioed his dispatcher to inform that he'd just picked up a fare and was headed for South Pacific Street. He didn't report back or respond to any further radio communications. After a considerable amount of time had passed with no contact from Ray, his employer notified police. A beach patrol discovered Ray's lifeless body later that morning in an alley off South Pacific Street in the upscale neighborhood of St. Malo. The 11.10 curbside pickup was Ray's last job for Checker Cab Company, his employer of less than four months. At some point during this trip, Ray's passenger pulled out a gun and fired it into the driver's seat, hitting Ray in the back.
第二天晚上，29岁的欧申赛德出租车司机雷·戴维斯将车停在使命大道市中心的出租车候客点。11点10分，一名乘客走近他的车并坐到了后座。雷通过无线电向调度员报告说，他刚接到一名乘客，正前往南太平洋街。他没有再回电，也没有回应任何进一步的无线电呼叫。在与雷失去联系过了相当长一段时间后，他的雇主报警了。当天晚些时候，海滩巡逻队在圣马洛高档社区南太平洋街的一条小巷里发现了雷毫无生气的尸体。11点10分的路边接客是雷在捷克出租车公司（Checker Cab Company）的最后一次出车，他在这家公司工作还不到四个月。在这次行程的某个时刻，雷的乘客掏出一枪，向驾驶座开枪，击中了雷的背部。
The shooter then aimed at Ray's head and pulled the trigger. The third and final bullet punctured the windshield, missing Ray completely. Two 22-caliber long rifle bullets were recovered from Ray's body. Despite their name, long rifle bullets could also be used in handguns. Ray's cab was found abandoned in an alley one and a half miles up the road. It appeared as though his killer had used the vehicle to facilitate a quicker getaway. Police were puzzled by the seemingly motiveless crime. Ray hadn't been robbed. His wallet had been left behind, as had a small amount of change in his shirt pocket.
凶手随后瞄准雷的头部扣动了扳机。第三发也是最后一发子弹击穿了挡风玻璃，完全打偏了。从雷的尸体中取出了两颗22口径长步枪子弹。尽管名字叫长步枪子弹，但它也可以用于手枪。雷的出租车被发现遗弃在前方一英里半的一条小巷里。凶手似乎利用这辆车来加快逃跑速度。这起看似毫无动机的犯罪让警方感到困惑。雷并没有被抢劫。他的钱包被留在了车里，衬衫口袋里还有一些零钱。
Nevertheless, unrelated armed robberies were examined for possible links. None were found. Both evidence and persons of interest were limited. Ray was relatively new to Oceanside, having moved there with his brother just four months earlier. He didn't have the community connections necessary to pat out a suspect list. Most of the individuals questioned were known petty criminals who were quickly ruled out. A fellow cabbie was also looked into, but accusations against him proved baseless. Then, four days after Ray Davis' murder, a second anonymous call was placed to Oceanside PD. Do you remember me calling you and telling you that I was going to pull a real baffling crime? The caller asked.
尽管如此，警方还是对不相关的武装抢劫案进行了调查，以寻找可能的联系。但什么也没有发现。证据和嫌疑人范围都非常有限。雷对欧申赛德来说还比较陌生，四个月前才和兄弟一起搬到那里。他没有列出嫌疑人名单所需的社区人脉。受讯问的大多数人都是众所周知的惯犯，并很快被排除在外。警方还调查了一位同行的出租车司机，但针对他的指控最终被证明毫无根据。接着，在雷·戴维斯遇害四天后，欧申赛德警察局接到了第二个匿名电话。“你还记得我给你打过电话，说我要搞一桩真正令人费解的犯罪吗？”打电话的人问道。
I killed the cab driver and I'm going to get me a bus driver next. Oceanside police took this very seriously. They had kept word of the initial call they received on April 9 under wraps, so they were certain they weren't dealing with a copycat or hoax. The caller had made good on his first threat by murdering Ray Davis, so there was a very real possibility he would follow through with the second. Faced with an unpredictable killer, the city manager gave officials blanket authority to take whatever steps necessary to protect Oceanside's 25 bus drivers. Buses and bus stops were placed under close observation. At night, military police from the nearby Marine Corps Base Camp stood guard over the nervous drivers on the lookout for any suspicious passengers. Four days after the second threat was made, a woman answered her telephone to hear a man warn,
“我杀那个出租车司机，接下来我要干掉一个公交车司机。”欧申赛德警方对此高度重视。他们对4月9日接到的第一通电话的消息保密得很好，因此他们确信这不是恶作剧或模仿犯罪。来电者通过谋杀雷·戴维斯兑现了他的第一个威胁，因此他很有可能会兑现第二个威胁。面对一个不可预测的凶手，城市经理赋予官员全权，采取一切必要措施保护欧申赛德的25名公交车司机。公交车和公交车站受到了密切监视。夜间，来自附近海军陆战队基地营地的宪兵守卫着紧张的司机，寻找任何可疑的乘客。发出第二个威胁四天后，一名女子接听了电话，听到一名男子警告说：
tonight is the night I'm going to kill that bus driver. The caller didn't give his name, but told the woman to relay the message to the police. They listened to her claim, while also being mindful that the case's notoriety would likely appeal to pranksters and attention seekers. The chaos was making headlines across the city, but concerns dissipated when the killer failed to carry out his second threat. As a precaution, two drivers were assigned to all buses that travelled lonely routes, but for the most part, life in Oceanside returned to normal. Eventually, the Ray Davis case went cold. At the time of his death, he was estranged from his wife and had no children. He was close to his brother and mother, but when they died many years later, Ray's senseless murder faded from California's memory.
今晚就是我要杀那个公交车司机的日子。来电者没有透露自己的姓名，但告诉这名女子将这条消息转达给警方。警方听取了她的说法，同时也注意到此案的恶名可能会吸引恶作剧者和寻求关注的人。这场混乱成为了全市各大媒体的头条新闻，但当凶手未能实施他的第二个威胁时，担忧情绪便消散了。作为预防措施，所有行驶在偏僻路线上的公交车都配备了两名司机，但在大多数情况下，欧申赛德的生活恢复了正常。最终，雷·戴维斯一案成了悬案。在他去世时，他与妻子分居且没有孩子。他和兄弟及母亲很亲近，但多年后他们去世时，雷这起毫无意义的谋杀案渐渐淡出了加利福尼亚人的记忆。
Decades later in 2018, local historian Christy Hawthorne donned a pair of white cotton gloves and began flipping through archived newspapers at an Oceanside museum. She had lived in the city since 1983 and harboured a deep passion for preserving its history. Christy was researching the St. Malo area when a three-word front-page headline caught her attention. Written in large, bold letters across a yellowed copy of the Daily Blade Tribune were the words, Local Cabbie Slain. Dated Wednesday, April 11, 1962, the accompanying article detailed the circumstances of Ray Davis's murder. Christy was unfamiliar with the case which had occurred more than half a century earlier. As she read on, her heart beat quickened. A cab driver, a .22 caliber firearm, long rifle ammunition, a city with a water-based name, a waterside crime scene, its proximity to a military base, lack of a motive or suspects, the randomness of the attack, and, most intriguing of all, a cryptic killer who taunted the police.
几十年后的2018年，当地历史学家克里斯蒂·霍桑戴上一副白色纯棉手套，开始翻阅欧申赛德博物馆里存档的报纸。自1983年以来她一直住在该市，并对保护当地历史怀有深厚的热情。克里斯蒂在研究圣马洛地区时，一个占据头版头条的三个字的标题吸引了她的注意。《每日刀锋论坛报》发黄的复印件上用醒目的大写粗体字写着：“当地出租车司机遇害”。文章日期为1962年4月11日星期三，随附的文章详细描述了雷·戴维斯谋杀案的经过。克里斯蒂对这起发生半个多世纪前的案件并不熟悉。随着她继续阅读，她的心跳加快了。一名出租车司机、一把22口径火器、长步枪弹药、一个名字带水的城市、一个水边的犯罪现场、毗邻军事基地、缺乏动机或嫌疑人、袭击的随机性，最引人入胜的是，一个戏弄警察的神秘凶手。
Alarm bells rang in Christy's mind. This seemed all too familiar. Daybreak on Sunday, June 2, 1963, one year after the murder of Ray Davis, near Gaviota, California. The sharp crack of gunshots echoed across the rolling landscape of Santa Barbara County. Three teenagers who were camping alongside Tejiga's Creek were alarmed by the unmistakable noise. It sounded as though the shots were fired just south of their location, where the creek filtered into the Pacific Ocean. There were no subsequent reports of damage or harm. It seemed as if the shooter had been firing for no reason at all. Later that same day, eleven teenagers were enjoying a day of surf and sand at a beach adjacent to Gaviota State Park, just seven miles west of Tejiga's Creek. By mid-afternoon, the teens had made their way back to the secluded spot just off Highway 101, where they'd parked their cars.
克里斯蒂的心中拉响了警报。这一切看起来太熟悉了。1963年6月2日星期日破晓时分，雷·戴维斯谋杀案发生一年后，加利福尼亚州加维奥塔附近。清脆的枪声在圣巴巴拉县起伏的山峦间回荡。三名在特吉加溪旁露营的青少年被这 unmistakably（难以错辨的）声音惊醒。听起来枪声似乎是从他们所在地正南方传来的，那里小溪流入太平洋。没有关于破坏或伤害的后续报告。看起来枪手是在毫无理由地开枪。当天晚些时候，十一名青少年在紧邻加维奥塔州立公园的一处海滩上享受冲浪和沙滩的一天，该海滩位于特吉加溪以西仅七英里处。到了下午中期，这些青少年回到了101高速公路旁他们停车的偏僻地点。
As they huddled around chatting, a loud cracking sound startled them. The noise was accompanied by a high-pitched whir as something small flew right by them. It was a bullet. Another quickly followed. No one was hit, but the teens were left shaken. They never caught sight of the shooter. Two days later, on Tuesday, June 4, eighteen-year-old Robert Dominguez was at the wheel of his family's 1956 Pontiac. Sitting beside him was his childhood sweetheart-turned-fiancé, seventeen-year-old Linda Redwoods. It was a special occasion for the pair. Both were senior students at Lompak High School and were due to graduate later in the week. That Tuesday was a ditch day, an official day off from classes for the graduating seniors. While their peers partied together, Robert and Linda decided to spend their free afternoon at a secluded beach near Gaviota State Park.
正当他们聚在一起聊天时，一声巨响吓了他们一跳。伴随着高亢的呼啸声，有什么小东西从他们身边飞过。是一颗子弹。紧接着又飞来一颗。没有人被击中，但这些青少年受到了惊吓。他们自始至终没有看到枪手的身影。两天后的6月4日星期二，18岁的罗伯特·多明格斯正开着他家的一辆1956年庞蒂亚克汽车。坐在他旁边的是他的青梅竹马兼未婚妻、17岁的琳达·雷德伍德。对这对情侣来说这是一个特殊的日子。两人都是隆波克高中的高年级学生，本该在本周晚些时候毕业。那个星期二是一个逃课日，是毕业班学生的官方放学日。当同龄人们聚在一起狂欢时，罗伯特和琳达决定在加维奥塔州立公园附近的一个偏僻海滩上度过他们自由的下午。
Linda had an additional reason to celebrate. Her eighteenth birthday was just three days away. It was around midday when the young couple hit the road for their trip to the coast. They reached Gaviota before continuing another four miles down Highway 101 to a dirt turnout that provided a good spot to pull over. After stripping down to their bathing suits, Robert and Linda crossed the road and began the arduous track down the hill to the beachfront below. Once there, they unraveled a blanket on a small patch of sand and laid down together. With no one else in sight, Robert and Linda believed they had the entire area to themselves. They were wrong. A man suddenly appeared before them.
琳达还有一个值得庆祝的理由。她的18岁生日就在三天后。正午时分，这对年轻的情侣踏上了前往海岸的旅程。他们到达加维奥塔，然后沿101高速公路继续行驶四英里，来到一个适合靠边停车的泥土岔路口。换上泳衣后，罗伯特和琳达穿过马路，开始了通往下方海滩的艰难跋涉。到达那里后，他们在仅有的一小片沙滩上铺开一条毯子，一起躺了下来。放眼望去空无一人，罗伯特和琳达以为整个地方都属于他们自己。他们错了。一个男人突然出现在他们面前。
He handed Linda a piece of rope and ordered that she tie Robert's hands behind his back. Terrified, she did as she was told. She didn't have a choice. The man was holding a gun. Once Robert was under control, the man set about restraining Linda. Before he could loop the rope and pull it tight, he was tackled by Robert, who had managed to wriggle free from his ligature. An altercation ensued. Despite sustaining several bruise-inducing blows to the face, Robert managed to overpower his opponent. He and Linda then ran for their lives. The gunman scrambled to his feet. The two teens hadn't gotten far.
他递给琳达一根绳子，命令她把罗伯特的双手反绑在身后。她吓坏了，只能照做。她别无选择。那个男人手里拿着枪。一旦罗伯特被控制住，那名男子便开始束缚琳达。在他还没来得及把绳子套上并拉紧之前，罗伯特猛扑过去将他扑倒，罗伯特已经设法从捆绑中挣脱了出来。一场搏斗随之展开。尽管面部挨了好几拳并留下了瘀伤，罗伯特还是成功制服了对手。他和琳达随后拼命逃跑。持枪歹徒挣扎着爬起身来。这两个年轻人并没有跑多远。
The only way out was up, and the rugged hillside was slowing their escape. The attacker raised his gun and took aim. He fired over and over until the chamber was empty and his targets had fallen. He reloaded, then marched intently to where his victims lay bleeding in the sand. He then shot them both several more times at close range. Robert was shot 11 times, Linda rate. After the slaughter, the shooter dragged Robert's body 30 feet across the rough terrain to a driftwood shack hidden in the bushes. He pulled Robert inside before collecting Linda and dumping her on top of her boyfriend.
唯一的出路就是往上爬，而崎岖的山坡减慢了他们逃跑的速度。袭击者举起枪瞄准。他一枪接一枪地开枪，直到弹匣打空，他的目标倒下。他重新装弹，然后大步走向他的受害者，他们正躺在沙滩上流血。随后，他在近距离对准他们俩又各开了数枪。罗伯特中弹11次，琳达中弹8次。大屠杀过后，凶手将罗伯特的尸体拖过30英尺崎岖不平的地形，拉到藏在灌木丛中的一个流木窝棚里。他把罗伯特拉了进去，然后把琳达也拖过来，扔在她男朋友的身上。
He then cut Linda's bathing suit open with a knife, exposing her breasts. It was easy to pull down the shack's dilapidated roof to conceal the bodies. After stacking further debris on top, the killer lit several matches and threw them at a tarpaulin covering the shack's entrance. It was time to leave. The fire would take care of the rest. It was nearing 10 o'clock the following night when California Highway Patrol Officer Paul Schultz drove along Highway 101, 22 miles southwest of Lompoc. The area was quiet, save for the sound of the sea crashing against the coastline. Officer Schultz approached a stretch of roadway south of Gaviota State Park, where three men were standing by the side of the road. One was George Dominguez, who was out looking for his son, Robert.
接着，他用刀划开琳达的泳衣，露出了她的胸部。推倒窝棚破旧的屋顶以掩盖尸体是轻而易举的事。在堆积了更多杂物之后，凶手划了几根火柴，扔在覆盖着窝棚入口的防水油布上。是时候离开了。大火会处理剩下的事情。第二天晚上快10点时，加利福尼亚州公路巡逻队警官保罗·舒尔茨沿着101高速公路行驶，位于隆波克西南22英里处。周围一片寂静，只有海浪拍打海岸线的声音。舒尔茨警官接近了加维奥塔州立公园以南的一段公路，三名男子正站在路边。其中一人是乔治·多明格斯，他出来寻找他的儿子罗伯特。
No one had heard from Robert or his fiance Linda since they left for the beach the day before. George Dominguez had gathered a small search party at the teen's last known location. They had since made an important discovery. The men led Officer Schultz to a turnout off the highway. Parked in the dirt by some bushes was the Dominguez family's Pontiac. The doors were locked. Three empty soda bottles were spotted within. Linda's purse lay on the floor in the front, and her and Robert's clothing was strewn about in the back. This confirmed the couple had made it to the beach, but they hadn't returned to the vehicle since.
自从罗伯特和他的未婚妻琳达前一天出发去海滩以来，就再也没有人听到他们的消息。乔治·多明格斯在青少年最后已知的位置召集了一支小型搜救队。此后他们有了重要发现。这几名男子带领舒尔茨警官来到高速公路旁的一个岔路口。多明格斯一家的庞蒂亚克汽车停在灌木丛旁的泥土地里。车门锁着。车内发现三个空苏打水瓶。琳达的手提包落在前排地板上，她和罗伯特的衣服则散落在后座上。这证实了这对情侣确实到了海滩，但之后就没有再回到车里。
One of George's companions informed Officer Schultz that there was a makeshift shack on the nearby beach where local youths were known to hang out. Schultz crossed the highway and headed towards the shore to check if the missing teens were there. It took a few minutes to hike down the steep, bush-lined trail to the water's edge. The secluded area attracted few visitors, aside from drifters who travelled along the nearby Southern Pacific Railroad. One had built the shack out of driftwood, cardboard, tin and grass among the trees and vegetation a few yards back from the water. When Officer Schultz reached the crudely built shack, it was in bad shape. Someone had tried to destroy it by pulling the roof down from within. Inside, partially concealed by the collapsed roof, was a horrific site.
乔治的一位同伴告诉舒尔茨警官，附近海滩上有一个临时搭建的窝棚，当地的年轻人在那里闲逛是出了名的。舒尔茨穿过高速公路，朝海岸走去，查看失踪的青少年是否在那里。沿着陡峭、灌木丛生的山路下行到水边花了几分钟。这处偏僻的地区很少吸引游客，除了沿附近南太平洋铁路出行的流浪汉。其中一人用浮木、硬纸板、锡皮和青草在水边几码外的树木和植被中搭建了这个窝棚。当舒尔茨警官到达这个简陋的窝棚时，它已经破烂不堪。有人曾试图从内部拉倒屋顶来摧毁它。里面是一个可怕的场景，被坍塌的屋顶遮掩了一部分。
The bloody bodies of Robert Dominguez and Linda Redwoods were piled one on top of the other. 22 calibre long rifle bullets, lengths of pre-cut cord and burnt-out matches found throughout the crime scene helped investigators piece together what likely happened. While Linda's bathing suit was cut open, there was no evidence that she had been sexually assaulted. Police were dealing with a particularly cunning offender, who had the foresight to stage the crime scene in an attempt to throw them off. It was clear the killer had hoped to cover up his crime by destroying the shack. But, unluckily for him, the matches snuffed out before the fire took hold. As both victims were popular and well liked, it was hard to identify a motive for the killings. But, not everyone was happy for the young couple.
罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·雷德伍德血肉模糊的尸体一具叠在另一具上面。现场发现的.22口径长步枪子弹、预先切好的绳索段和烧焦的火柴，帮助调查人员拼凑出了可能发生的事情。虽然琳达的泳衣被割开了，但没有证据表明她遭到过性侵犯。警方面对的是一个格外狡猾的罪犯，他具有远见，试图伪造犯罪现场来误导警方。很明显，凶手希望通过烧毁窝棚来掩盖罪行。但对凶手来说不幸的是，火势蔓延之前火柴就熄灭了。由于两名受害者都很受欢迎且人缘很好，很难确定杀戮的动机。但是，并不是所有人都为这对年轻情侣感到高兴。
17 year old Jason, not his real name, was known to be openly jealous of Robert Dominguez. Robert was a star player on the school's football team and was dating a cheerleader, whereas Jason was in and out of trouble with police. He'd been arrested multiple times, including immediately after the murders for causing trouble while intoxicated. On the day of the double homicide, Jason was at a beach four miles from the one Robert and Linda were visiting. During questioning, police noticed that Jason's hand was bruised as though he'd been in a fight. He also admitted to having access to his father's guns. Still, there was nothing directly linking Jason to the murders, and he was released without charge. After speaking with locals, railroad men and youths that frequented the beach area, investigators became aware of a 50 year old army veteran turned drifter named George Gill.
17岁的杰森（化名）是出了名的公开嫉妒罗伯特·多明格斯。罗伯特是学校橄榄球队的明星球员，还在和一个啦啦队员交往，而杰森则三番两次惹上警察麻烦。他曾多次被捕，包括在谋杀案发生后不久因醉酒滋事而被捕。在双重谋杀案发生的当天，杰森正在距离罗伯特和琳达游玩海滩四英里外的一个海滩上。在接受讯问时，警察注意到杰森的手上有瘀伤，看起来像是打过架。他也承认自己可以接触到他父亲的枪支。尽管如此，没有任何证据直接将杰森与谋杀案联系起来，他在没有被起诉的情况下获释。在与当地人、铁路工人和经常光顾海滩的年轻人交谈后，调查人员注意到了一名50岁、曾当过士兵后流浪的男子，名叫乔治·吉尔。
A loner with a penchant for military style clothing, Gill visited the Gaviota beach often, surviving on the pelicans, mussels and wild mustard he found there. Gill had actually built the shack where Robert and Linda's bodies were found, and was reportedly living in it in the days prior to the murders. He kept a .22 caliber rifle in a bundle strapped to his back, which he was seen firing in the area. Could Gill have been responsible for the gunshots heard and even felt by the two groups of teenagers near Tahiga's Creek and Gaviota State Park in the days before Robert and Linda were killed? The teens had described the gunfire as having come from a .22 caliber semi-automatic firearm, possibly a long rifle. There was no way to know for sure. By the time Gill was brought to police attention, he was long gone. The bullets recovered from Robert and Linda's bodies were too versatile to isolate exactly what type of firearm they came from. But the discovery of several boxes of Winchester-Western Super-X long rifle ammunition inside the beach shack helped direct detectives to the bullet's origin.
吉尔是一个独行侠，偏爱军装风格的服装，经常光顾加维奥塔海滩，靠在那里找到的鹈鹕、贻贝和野芥菜维生。吉尔实际上就是罗伯特和琳达尸体被发现的那个窝棚的建造者，据报道在谋杀案发生前的几天里他一直住在里面。他背上绑着一个包裹，里面藏着一把.22口径步枪，有人看到他在该地区开枪。吉尔会不会是罗伯特和琳达遇害前几天在特吉加溪和加维奥塔州立公园附近的两群青少年听到甚至感受到枪声的罪魁祸首？青少年们曾将枪声描述为来自一把.22口径半自动火器，很可能是一支长步枪。没有办法确切知道了。当吉尔进入警方视线时，他早已不知所踪。从罗伯特和琳达尸体中取出的子弹具有极高的通用性，无法明确锁定它们来自哪种特定火器。但海滩窝棚内发现的几盒温彻斯特-西部超级X（Winchester-Western Super-X）长步枪弹药帮助侦探锁定了子弹的来源。
The boxes, one empty and three partially filled, featured a lot number, TL-21. While this batch was stocked in local sports stores, it was also sold at a base exchange at the Vandenberg Air Force Base, just over 9 miles from Lompoc. Yet, the boxes lacked any identifiers that could help narrow down where or when they were purchased. As these bullets were also the most popular and common type of ammunition purchased, it was difficult to isolate a suspect using this evidence alone. The graduation ceremony for Lompoc High's senior class of 1963 was held on Thursday June 6, the day after Robert Dominguez and Linda Edwards were found murdered. The mood amongst the students was somber, and they laid wreaths on two empty seats in honor of their slain classmates. That same day, two teens were transferred to Santa Barbara County Sheriff's Department, having just confessed to witnessing a murder. Daytime on Friday May 31, 1963, four days before the murders of Robert Dominguez and Linda Edwards, in Santa Cruz, California.
这些盒子，一个空的，三个半满，上面印有一个批号：TL-21。虽然这批货物在当地的体育用品商店有售，但它也在距离隆波克仅9英里多一点的范登堡空军基地的基地小卖部出售。然而，这些盒子上没有任何标识可以帮助缩小购买地点或时间的范围。由于这些子弹也是购买量最大、最常见的弹药类型，仅凭这一证据很难孤立出嫌疑人。1963届隆波克高中高年级毕业典礼于6月6日星期四举行，也就是罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·爱德华兹被发现遇害的第二天。学生们的情绪十分低落，他们为了纪念被害的同班同学，在两个空座位上摆放了花圈。同一天，两名青少年被移交给圣巴巴拉县警长办公室，他们刚刚承认目击了一场谋杀。1963年5月31日星期五白天，在罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·爱德华兹谋杀案发生四天前，地点加利福尼亚州圣克鲁斯。
16-year-old James Coleman and his friend, 17-year-old JC Reed Jr., eyed the stranger before them. He was maybe a year or two older than them, of average height and build, with thick natural blonde hair combed to one side. A pair of black-rimmed prescription eyeglasses framed his pale blue eyes. In between taking drags from a pal-mouthed cigarette he held at the base of his fingers, the stranger introduced himself as Sandy and said he'd run away from his home in San Francisco. Sandy's story was inconsistent. Each time he told it, the details varied slightly. Whatever the truth, Sandy was a transient who'd taken to sleeping under the Santa Cruz boardwalk. His peculiarities soon made him a recognizable figure to locals, who thought his army fatigues were an odd choice of attire for someone living on the beach. Sandy often asked other young men where he could find girls, even though girls clearly weren't interested in him.
16岁的詹姆斯·科尔曼和他的朋友、17岁的J·C·里德二世打量着眼前的陌生人。他可能比他们大一两岁，中等身高和身材，浓密的天然金发梳向一边。一副黑框处方眼镜框住了他苍白蓝色的眼睛。在一边抽着夹在指根处的一支平口香烟的同时，陌生人自我介绍叫桑迪，并说他是从旧金山的家中逃出来的。桑迪的故事前后矛盾。每次他讲述时，细节都会略有不同。不管真相如何，桑迪是一个开始睡在圣克鲁斯木栈道底下的流浪汉。他的古怪之处很快使他成为当地人熟悉的人物，他们认为他穿的军服对于一个住在海滩上的人来说是一个奇怪的选择。桑迪经常问其他年轻男子他在哪里可以找到女孩，尽管女孩们显然对毫无兴趣。
On one occasion, Sandy received a warning from police after a young woman complained that he'd been bothering her. While Sandy's requests for food or drinks from passers-by weren't particularly unusual, he raised eyebrows when he produced a knife and asked where he could get it sharpened. There was no doubt that Sandy was a strange character, but James Coleman and JC Reed Jr. were somewhat charmed by him. On the day they met, the trio teamed up and embarked on a crime spree that led them 200 miles south to Lompoc. Coleman and Reed weren't new to petty crime, but Sandy's influence seemingly emboldened them to commit increasingly violent acts. First, they stole some drinks from a YMCA, then they robbed a woman of $20. Next, they stole a sunbeam convertible. During their misadventures, Coleman and Reed gifted Sandy a pair of black pants and a black slip-over shirt with a button-down collar.
有一次，一名年轻女子抱怨桑迪一直在纠缠她后，桑迪收到了警方的警告。虽然桑迪向路人索要食物或饮料并不算特别寻常，但当他掏出一把刀并询问哪里可以把它磨锋利时，他还是让人侧目。毫无疑问，桑迪是一个奇怪的角色，但詹姆斯·科尔曼和J·C·里德二世在某种程度上被他吸引了。在他们相遇的那天，三人一拍即合，开始了一场犯罪狂欢，一路向南200英里来到了隆波克。科尔曼和里德对轻微犯罪并不陌生，但桑迪的影响似乎助长了他们犯下越来越暴力的行为。首先，他们从基督教青年会偷了一些饮料，然后他们抢劫了一名妇女20美元。接下来，他们偷了一辆阳光牌敞篷车。在他们的胡闹期间，科尔曼和里德送给桑迪一条黑裤子和一个带有纽扣领的黑色套头衫。
They also supplied him with a yellow-handled fishing knife, though Sandy desired a deadlier weapon. He kept talking about wanting to procure a .22 caliber rifle. In Lompoc later that night, they approached 63-year-old quarry worker Vernon Smith with the intention of robbing him. Sandy asked for Vernon's help, explaining that they'd run out of gas. As Vernon used a gas can to fill the tank of the stolen sunbeam, Sandy walked up behind him and pulled out his fishing knife. This wasn't part of the plan. Coleman yelled at Sandy. Don't do it, boy.
他们还给他提供了一把黄柄钓鱼刀，尽管桑迪渴望得到更致命的武器。他一直喋喋不休地谈论着想要弄到一把.22口径步枪。当天晚些时候在隆波克，他们接近了63岁的采石场工人弗农·史密斯，企图抢劫他。桑迪请求弗农帮忙，解释说他们的汽油用完了。当弗农用油桶给偷来的阳光牌汽车加油时，桑迪走到他身后拔出了他的钓鱼刀。这不是计划的一部分。科尔曼向桑迪大喊。别这么做，伙计。
Sandy ignored him and plunged the knife into Vernon's back, killing him. Stunned by the sudden and brutal attack, Coleman asked Sandy why he did it. Sandy shrugged and with cool indifference said he didn't know. He then laughed as if the whole thing was a joke. The murder marked the end of Sandy's time with Coleman and Reid. Unnerved, the boys ditched Sandy at a motel in a Royal Grande, 45 miles north of Lompoc. The very next day, Robert Dominguez and Linda Edwards were shot dead on Gaviota Beach. Police caught up with the James Coleman and JC Reid Jr. and arrested them in relation to one of the robberies they committed during their crime spree.
桑迪不理睬他，把刀刺进弗农的背部，杀死了他。面对突如其来的残酷袭击，科尔曼感到震惊，他问桑迪为什么要这么做。桑迪耸了耸肩，冷漠地说他不知道。然后他大笑起来，好像整件事只是个笑话。这起谋杀标志着桑迪与科尔曼和里德的相处时间的结束。感到不安的男孩们在距离隆波克以北45英里的阿罗约格兰德的一家汽车旅馆抛弃了桑迪。就在第二天，罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·爱德华兹在加维奥塔海滩被枪杀。警方追查到詹姆斯·科尔曼和J·C·里德二世，并因他们在此次犯罪狂欢中犯下的其中一起抢劫案而将其逮捕。
When grilled about Vernon Smith's murder, the pair quickly implicated Sandy, but neither could provide his full name. They weren't even certain if he was really named Sandy. While police were wary of Coleman and Reid's story, it appeared to be the truth. Other people confirmed Sandy's existence and he had been sighted with Coleman and Reid in Lompoc. One witness recalled him carrying a yellow-handled fishing knife, exactly like the one Coleman and Reid said he used to kill Vernon Smith. There had been no sightings of Sandy since Coleman and Reid abandoned him at the motel in a Royal Grande, but police were able to piece together his possible movements. After killing Vernon Smith, Sandy had pocketed $20. It was believed that he used some of this money to fund an overnight stay at the motel.
当被严厉审问关于弗农·史密斯的谋杀案时，两人很快供出了桑迪，但谁也说不出他的全名。他们甚至不确定他是不是真的叫桑迪。虽然警方对科尔曼和里德的说法持警惕态度，但它似乎是事实。其他人证实了桑迪的存在，并且有人看到他与科尔曼和里德在隆波克出现过。一名目击者回忆说他带着一把黄柄钓鱼刀，正如科尔曼和里德所说他用来杀死弗农·史密斯的那把一模一样。自从科尔曼和里德在阿罗约格兰德的汽车旅馆抛弃桑迪以来，就再也没有人见过他，但警方能够拼凑出他可能的动向。杀死弗农·史密斯后，桑迪口袋里揣着20美元。据信他用这部分钱资助了在汽车旅馆过夜的费用。
He booked a room using the pseudonym William Carr and a fake address before checking out at 11 the following morning. A seasoned hitchhiker, Sandy would have been capable of securing a ride further south. He could have obtained a gun and ammunition at any point throughout his journey. Known for approaching locals and begging for help, someone might have told him he could stay at the beach shack near Gabiota State Park. No stranger to sleeping rough, Sandy would have been comfortable hold up there for a night. He might have spotted Robert Dominguez and Linda Redwoods arriving the next day. Sandy was carrying at least one knife which he could have used to cut the rope ligatures as well as Linda's bathing suit. Given he was a smoker, it was likely he would have been carrying a pack of matches.
他使用威廉·卡尔（William Carr）这个化名和假地址登记了一个房间，然后在第二天早上11点退房。作为一名经验丰富的搭便车者，桑迪有能力搭车去更南边的地方。他本可以在旅途中的任何时候获取枪支和弹药。由于众所周知他会接近当地人并乞求帮助，可能有人告诉他可以住在加维奥塔州立公园附近的海滩窝棚里。对露宿并不陌生的桑迪，在那里安顿一晚会觉得很舒适。他可能在第二天发现罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·雷德伍德到达。桑迪随身携带至少一把刀，他可以用它来割断绳索以及琳达的泳衣。鉴于他是个烟民，他很可能随身携带一包火柴。
This timeline, coupled with Sandy's willingness to kill and desire to obtain a .22 caliber firearm, put him high on the list of suspects in the double homicide. The hunt for Sandy was on. A composite sketch was created based on descriptions from those who had interacted with him. Police dubbed him the laughing boy and the laughing killer due to his amused demeanor following the stabbing of Vernon Smith. Alleged sightings of Sandy were reported across the state. Sacramento teen Robert Lee Bell was one such lookalike. The 17-year-old raised eyebrows when he abruptly quit his job at a Lompoc car wash and skipped town days before the Dominguez-Edwards murders. Before he left, he stole a .22 caliber rifle and ammunition.
这个时间线，加上桑迪杀人的意愿和获得.22口径火器的渴望，使他在这起双重谋杀案的嫌疑人名单中名列前茅。对桑迪的搜捕随即展开。根据与他有过接触的人的描述，警方制作了一张合成素描。由于他在刺死弗农·史密斯后表现出的愉悦神态，警方给他起了个绰号叫“爱笑的男孩”和“爱笑的杀手”。全州各地都有人报告说疑似看到了桑迪。萨克拉门托少年罗伯特·李·贝尔就是这样一个相貌相似的人。这名17岁的少年在多明格斯-爱德华兹谋杀案发生的几天前，突然辞去了隆波克洗车场的工作并逃离了该镇，这让人感到意外。在他离开之前，他偷了一把.22口径步枪和弹药。
When police tracked Bell down, he still had the gun in his possession. Week-old scratches marked his wrists and forearms, but Bell insisted they'd been caused by a puppy. Ballistics confirmed that Bell's rifle wasn't the murder weapon, and when several witnesses placed him at a Sacramento baseball game on the day of the shooting, he was dropped as a suspect. Bell was just one of several young men suspected of being Sandy. While some owned or had access to .22 caliber firearms, investigators couldn't connect any of these weapons to the crime. Clues were scarce, and those police did have were confusing. Sandy had left behind a green military jacket, which had the name Robert Kaufman scrawled along the inside of the collar. Coleman and Reid recalled Sandy saying he had stolen the jacket and the rest of his army clothes.
当警察追踪到贝尔时，他身上依然持有那把枪。他的手腕和前臂上有着一周前的抓痕，但贝尔坚称那是小狗造成的。弹道学证实贝尔的步枪不是凶器，而且当几名目击者证实他在枪击当天在萨克拉门托看棒球比赛时，他被取消了嫌疑人身份。贝尔只是几名被怀疑是桑迪的年轻男子之一。虽然有些人拥有或能够接触到.22口径火器，但调查人员无法将这些武器中的任何一个与犯罪联系起来。线索十分稀少，而警察掌握的线索又令人困惑。桑迪留下一件绿色军用夹克，领子内侧潦草地写着“罗伯特·考夫曼”这个名字。科尔曼和里德回忆说，桑迪曾说过这件夹克和其余的军装是他偷的。
It was also possible that Kaufman was just another of Sandy's aliases. Either way, the name was a dead end. For their involvement in the killing of Vernon Smith, James Coleman and JC Reid Jr. played a guilty to conspiracy to commit robbery and second-degree murder. They were sent to prison, while the person they alleged had committed the slaying remained on the run. The evening of Wednesday, February 5, 1964, eight months after the murders of Robert Dominguez and Linda Redwoods in Ocean Beach, California. Although Johnny and Joyce Swindle had only been staying in Ocean Beach for a week, they'd already formed a nightly routine. The newlyweds, aged 20 and 19 respectively, did everything together, from washing the dishes to making their bed. Every evening, they left their rented bungalow to take a stroll down to the beach.
考夫曼也可能只是桑迪的另一个化名。无论如何，这个名字是一条死胡同。由于参与谋杀弗农·史密斯，詹姆斯·科尔曼和J·C·里德二世对谋杀阴谋和二级谋杀罪名认罪。他们被送进监狱，而他们指控实施谋杀的人仍然在逃。1964年2月5日星期三傍晚，加利福尼亚州海洋海滩，罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·雷德伍德谋杀案发生八个月后。尽管强尼和乔伊斯·斯温德尔在海洋海滩只呆了一个星期，但他们已经形成了一套夜间惯例。这对新婚夫妇分别20岁和19岁，做什么都在一起，从洗碗到铺床。每天晚上，他们都会离开租来的平房，散步去海滩。
The night of February 5 was no different, except for a brief visit to a pharmacy where Johnny purchased a red heart-shaped box of candy for his wife. Valentine's Day was more than a week away, but it didn't matter. The childhood sweethearts had been on Cloud 9 since their wedding three weeks earlier. The couple continued their usual walk, which ended nine blocks from their home at the beach front. Joyce in particular loved the ocean. It fascinated her, and Johnny couldn't keep her away. During the day, Ocean Beach foreshore was a hive of activity. Tourists and fishermen lined its pier as swimmers took to the surf below. Just left of the pier at the foot of Narragansett Avenue was a wide concrete patio that provided uninterrupted views of the ocean. It was the perfect spot to observe the sunset. By late evening, most beachgoers had retreated like the tide, leaving the area peaceful and private.
2月5日的夜晚也没有什么不同，只是去了一趟药店，强尼在那里为妻子买了一盒红色的心形糖果。情人节还有一周多才到，但这并不重要。这对青梅竹马自三周前结婚以来就一直沉浸在九霄云上。这对夫妇继续他们通常的散步，散步在距离他们家九个街区的海滨结束。乔伊斯尤其喜欢大海。它令她着迷，强尼无法阻止她靠近。白天，海洋海滩前滨是一个充满活力的活动中心。游客和渔民排成一队在防波堤上，而游泳者则下到下方的海浪中。防波堤左侧、纳拉甘西特大道脚下是一个宽阔的混凝土露台，可以一览无遗地欣赏海景。这里是观赏日落的绝佳地点。到了深夜，大多数海滩游客像潮水一样退去，留下了宁静和私密的空间。
Placing the candy box on the retaining wall framing the water, Johnny and Joyce snuggled together, oblivious to anyone but each other. All of a sudden, Johnny was struck in the back by something small but powerful. He barely had time to register the accompanying pain before Joyce collapsed into his arms. She too had been hit in the upper back. Quickly realizing that they were being shot at, Johnny turned his body into the line of fire trying to shield his wife from the barrage. His pained cries of no, no, carried up the cliffside to the apartment buildings above. Johnny's left thigh was hit and another bullet struck the right side of his head. A bullet pierced Joyce's left arm.
强尼把糖果盒放在构成水景框架的挡土墙上，两人依偎在一起，除了彼此，对外面的世界一无所知。突然，强尼的背部被一个体积小但威力强大的东西击中了。他几乎没有时间意识到随之而来的痛苦，乔伊斯就瘫倒在他的怀里。她也被击中了上背部。很快意识到他们正遭到枪击，强尼将身体转向火线，试图保护妻子免受弹雨袭击。他痛苦的“不，不”的喊声传到了悬崖上方的公寓楼里。强尼的左大腿中弹，另一颗子弹击中了头部右侧。一颗子弹穿透了乔伊斯的左臂。
Exposed and unable to see their assailant in the dark, the couple crumpled helplessly to the ground. With his victims immobilized, the shooter eased down the rocky cliff face to the patio below. Joyce was facedown when he marched up and shot her at point blank range in the back of the head. Then he turned towards Johnny who had collapsed against the retaining wall and fired a bullet into his left ear. After rummaging through Johnny's pockets and taking whatever he could find, the killer then fled the scene. A short while later, Ocean Beach local Edward Nelson descended the steps that led to the patio overlooking the sea. Spotting something on the ground ahead, Edward raised his flashlight, illuminating two bodies piled on top of one another. Edward suspected he had stumbled across a pair of drunk lovers who had passed out together.
由于暴露在外且在黑暗中看不到袭击者，这对夫妇无助地瘫倒在地上。由于受害者失去了行动能力，枪手从岩石悬崖面上轻松走下来，来到下方的露台。当他大步走过去并在近距离朝乔伊斯的后脑勺开枪时，她正脸朝下趴着。然后他转向靠在挡土墙上瘫倒的强尼，向他的左耳开了一枪。在翻找强尼的口袋并拿走他能找到的一切后，凶手逃离了现场。不久之后，海洋海滩当地人爱德华·纳尔逊走下通往俯瞰大海露台的台阶。爱德华发现前方地上有什么东西，便举起手电筒，照亮了叠在一起的两具尸体。爱德华怀疑自己偶然遇到了一对一起昏迷过去的醉酒恋人。
Edging closer, his flashlight reflected off something glistening and red. Underneath the couple was a large pool of blood. Two empty 22 calibre long rifle cartridges lay nearby. Matching shells were also found on a dark, well-hidden cliff top, 50 feet above. By the time Edward found the swindles, it was too late for Joyce. However, Johnny was clinging to life. Gurgling and gasping for air, he managed to weakly lift himself up and drape one arm over his wife's body. Witnesses heard him splutter.
走近一看，他的手电筒反射出某种闪闪发光的红色东西。这对夫妇身下一大滩血。附近躺着两个空的22口径长步枪弹壳。在上方50英尺处一个黑暗、隐蔽的悬崖顶部也发现了相匹配的弹壳。当爱德华找到斯温德尔夫妇时，对乔伊斯来说已经太晚了。然而，强尼还在垂死挣扎。他咕哝着喘着气，勉强虚弱地直起身体，把一只手臂搭在妻子的尸体上。目击者听到他结结巴巴地说。
My God, how much blood does a person have? He lost consciousness and was taken to hospital, where he died less than three hours later. While no one saw the shooting take place, an unidentified man was spotted standing on the rocks near the patio shortly before the swindles arrived. 15 minutes later, another witness saw a man running at full speed along Del Monte Avenue away from the beachfront. It couldn't be ascertained exactly what type of firearm was used in the crime. A sniper rifle correlated with the crime scene's layout and the position of the shooter. However, the erratic gunfire and execution-style headshots were more in line with someone wielding a handgun. Although Johnny's wallet had been stolen, robbery didn't appear to have been the killer's true motive.
天哪，一个人有多少血？他失去了知觉，被送到医院，不到三小时后死亡。虽然没有人看到枪击事件的发生，但在斯温德尔夫妇到达之前，曾看到一名身份不明的男子站在露台附近的岩石上。15分钟后，另一名目击者看到一名男子沿德尔蒙特大道全速奔跑，远离海滨。无法确定犯罪中究竟使用了哪种火器。狙击步枪与犯罪现场的布局和枪手的位置相吻合。然而，反复无常的枪击和行刑式的头部枪击更符合挥舞手枪的人。尽管强尼的钱包被偷了，但抢劫似乎并不是凶手的真正动机。
Johnny was so short on cash that he'd started painting for his landlord in lieu of paying rent, making it unlikely that he had much money on him. Robbery might have been the killer's secondary motive, or merely an afterthought intended to confuse investigators. There was little in the victim's lives that indicated the crime was personal. Johnny and Joyce had barely settled into their apartment, where they kept to themselves. They were making the most of their honeymoon period before Johnny reported for naval duty aboard a radar picket ship. Nothing in their backgrounds pointed to someone they knew wanting to kill them. Police concluded that the crime was a senseless thrill-killing committed by a psychopathic killer whose only motive was excitement. With the murders of Johnny and Joyce Swindle, a pattern was beginning to emerge.
强尼手头很紧，以至于他开始为房东画画来代替交租，这使得他身上不太可能有很多钱。抢劫可能是凶手的次要动机，或者只是为了混淆调查人员视线的事后想法。受害者的生活中几乎没有什么迹象表明这起犯罪是针对个人的。强尼和乔伊斯刚安顿在他们的公寓里，平时深居简出。在强尼作为海军雷达警戒舰服役之前，他们正在充分享受蜜月期。他们的背景中没有任何迹象表明他们认识的人想要杀害他们。警方得出结论，这起犯罪是一起毫无意义的快感杀人案，由一个唯一的动机就是刺激的精神病杀手所为。随着强尼和乔伊斯·斯温德尔的谋杀案发生，一种模式开始显现。
The similarities between the Swindle's killing and that of Robert Dominguez and Linda Edwards less than a year prior was not lost on investigators. A young couple, a .22 caliber firearm, long rifle ammunition, a water-side crime scene, lack of motive or suspects, the randomness of the attack. Although ballistics confirmed that a different gun was used in each crime, a lingering suspicion remained that one person was responsible for both. Three days after the murders of Johnny and Joyce Swindle, a priest sat in the confessional of St. Joseph's Catholic Church in San Diego. It wasn't long before he heard a footfall echoing off the terracotta tiles as someone made their way down the center aisle. The footsteps stopped at the confessional. A man took a seat inside, cleared his throat, and said, Bless me, Father, for I have sinned. I have an urge to hurt someone. Anyone.
斯温德尔夫妇的遇害与不到一年前罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·爱德华兹的遇害之间的相似之处并没有被调查人员忽视。年轻的情侣、22口径火器、长步枪弹药、水边犯罪现场、缺乏动机或嫌疑人、袭击的随机性。虽然弹道学证实每起犯罪使用的枪支不同，但仍然存在一种挥之不去的怀疑，即一个人对这两起案件负有责任。强尼和乔伊斯·斯温德尔被谋杀三天后，一位神父坐在圣地亚哥圣约瑟夫天主教堂的告解室里。没过多久，当有人沿着中央过道走来时，他就听到了一声脚印在红土砖瓦上回响的声音。脚步声在告解室停了下来。一名男子在里面坐下，清了清嗓子，说道：“神父，请宽恕我，因为我有罪。我有伤害某人的冲动。任何人都可以。”
The priest paused, uncertain of what to say. Before he could respond, the man leapt from his seat and ran from the church. The confessor was identified as 18-year-old Rene Leon Trudeau. A transient who worked part-time as a janitor, Rene was arrested and booked at the city jail on suspicion of murdering the Swindles. He told the arresting officer, I would hurt you if I had the chance, any way I could. That's why I saw the priest. I guess I need help. With no evidence to tie him to the double homicide, Rene was released without charge. Across the Pacific Ocean in Hawaii, television repairman Michael Patrick Moeller purchased a gun on a whim. The 23-year-old made his way up the steep mountainside five miles outside of Honolulu to the Pali Lookout.
神父停顿了一下，不确定该说什么。在他反应过来之前，这名男子从座位上跳起来跑出了教堂。告解者被识别为18岁的勒内·莱昂·特鲁多（Rene Leon Trudeau）。勒内是一名兼职清洁工的流浪汉，因涉嫌谋杀斯温德尔夫妇而被捕并被关押在城市监狱。他对逮捕他的警官说：“如果有机会，我会用我能用的任何方式伤害你。这就是我见神父的原因。我想我需要帮助。”由于没有证据将他与这起双重谋杀案联系起来，勒内被无罪释放。在太平洋对岸的夏威夷，电视修理工迈克尔·帕特里克·莫勒（Michael Patrick Moeller）一时兴起买了一把枪。这位23岁的年轻人沿着檀香山郊外五英里处的陡峭山坡向上走去，来到了帕利瞭望台。
The mountain provided stunning panoramic views across the island of Oahu, but Moeller wasn't there to enjoy the scenery. Instead, he crouched amongst the dense vegetation and raised his firearm. He watched as a tourist bus descended on the area. With his sights set on the vehicle, he pulled the trigger. His shooting spree continued for five hours. By the end, four people were injured and a highway patrolman had lost his life. Moeller blamed the attack on his mental health. It wasn't the first time something like this had happened. He'd previously committed another sniping in Germany while serving in the US Air Force. Investigators fronting the swindle case arrived in Hawaii and entered the state hospital ward. They made their way to the psychiatric ward where Michael Patrick Moeller was being held.
这座山可以俯瞰瓦胡岛的全景，但莫勒不是来欣赏风景的。相反，他蹲在茂密的植被中，举起了武器。他看着一辆旅游巴士开进这片区域。他将准星对准车辆，扣动了扳机。他的枪击狂潮持续了五个小时。最终，四人受伤，一名公路巡警殉职。莫勒将这次袭击归咎于自己的心理健康。这并不是第一次发生这样的事。他此前在美国空军服役时，曾在德国制造过另一起狙击事件。负责这起诈骗案的调查人员抵达夏威夷，进入了州立医院的病房。他们来到了迈克尔·帕特里克·莫勒被关押的精神病房。
With his military ties and known love of guns, police considered whether Moeller could also be responsible for the swindle's murder or that of Robert Dominguez and Linda Redwoods. Moeller told police that at the time the newlyweds were killed, he was undergoing psychiatric care in Texas in response to the German shooting. His alibi checked out. Moeller was cleared. It was approaching midnight on December 1, 1964 when Santa Ana city patrolman James Pico pulled up at a ramshackle campsite near the Santa Fe Railroad tracks. A woman had called police to report some property damage and she suspected a person at the camp was responsible. Pico had arrived to do a routine check of the site which consisted of makeshift shelters used by itinerants and the homeless. One person in particular caught the officer's attention. A tall and thin reclusive man in his 50s with blue eyes receding brown hair and a sullo weather beaten face.
鉴于他的军方背景和众所周知的对枪支的热爱，警方开始怀疑莫勒是否也应对这起诈骗案中的谋杀案，或者罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·雷德伍德的遇害负责。莫勒告诉警方，在新婚夫妇被杀时，他在德克萨斯州接受针对德国枪击事件的精神病治疗。他的不在场证明得到了证实。莫勒被洗清了嫌疑。1964年12月1日午夜临近时，圣安娜市巡警詹姆斯·皮科将车停在圣达菲铁路轨道旁的一个简陋营地附近。一名女子打电话报警称有些财产受到破坏，她怀疑是营地里的人干的。皮科赶来对该地点进行例行检查，这里由流浪者和无家可归者搭建的临时避难所组成。其中一个人特别引起了警官的注意。一个50多岁的高瘦孤僻男子，蓝眼睛，棕色头发后退，面容饱经风霜。
Pico obtained the man's name and ran a background check. It turned out he was wanted for questioning in relation to the murders of Robert Dominguez and Linda Redwoods. Pico had inadvertently found George Gill, the drifter who had built the beach shack where the teenagers bodies were discovered. Gill had been on quite a journey in the year and a half he'd been avoiding police, funding part of his near 200 mile trip south by selling pistols he had stolen from a retreat in San Diego. He also sold a knife for bus fare. Witnesses claimed that Gill was living out of the shack when the murders took place, but Gill insisted he'd left before then. He agreed to take a polygraph test, but an inconclusive result only propelled Gill into further suspicion. Yet, his alibi placing him in San Jose for work checked out and George Gill, like many others, was scrubbed from the suspect list.
皮科获取了该男子的姓名并进行了背景调查。结果发现他因涉嫌罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·雷德伍德的谋杀案而被通缉。皮科无意中找到了乔治·吉尔，那个流浪汉，也就是青少年的尸体被发现的那间海滩小屋的建造者。在躲避警方的的一年半时间里，吉尔经历了一段漫长的旅程，他通过出售从圣地亚哥一处静修处偷来的手枪，资助了自己近200英里南下之旅的一部分。他还卖掉了一把刀来换取车费。目击者称，谋杀发生时吉尔正住在木屋里，但吉尔坚称他在那之前就已经离开了。他同意接受测谎仪测试，但含糊不清的结果让吉尔陷入了更深的怀疑。然而，他有在圣荷西工作的正当不在场证明，乔治·吉尔和许多其他人一样，从嫌疑人名单中被划掉了。
On Wednesday, September 28, 1966, two and a half years after the swindles were gunned down, three residents of a San Diego apartment complex noticed something strange. There was a young man loitering outside the building. They didn't recognise him, and as it was almost 11 o'clock at night, his presence seemed suspicious. The concerned residents decided to approach the stranger. They greeted the young man and asked what he was doing in the neighbourhood, when suddenly he pulled out a pistol. If you value your lives, you'd better run for it, he warned. The trio wasted no time. As they bolted away from the young man, they heard a shot ring out behind them.
1966年9月28日星期三，在斯温德尔夫妇被枪杀两年半后，圣地亚哥一处公寓大楼的三名居民注意到了奇怪的事情。大楼外有一个年轻人徘徊。他们不认识他，而且当时已经是晚上11点左右，他的出现显得很可疑。这几位热心的居民决定上前与陌生人交谈。他们向年轻人打招呼，问他在附近做什么，突然他掏出了一支手枪。如果你们珍惜生命，最好快跑，他警告说。三人没有浪费时间。当他们从年轻人身边飞奔逃离时，他们听到身后响了一声枪响。
Luckily, none of them were struck by the bullet. Another resident later reported that the young man had also fired at him, sniper style. Flagging down a nearby police officer, the trio explained what had happened and to jump in the patrol car to track down the shooter. It didn't take long. They soon spotted the young man crossing Mission Boulevard, and the officer turned his car around to give chase. Realising he was being pursued, the shooter ran towards a nearby hotel and vanished into the night. The policeman radioed for backup, prompting other officers to descend on the scene. Together they began scouring the grounds of the hotel, their flashlights cutting through the darkness.
幸运的是，他们中没有人被子弹击中。另一位居民后来报告说，这名年轻人也像狙击手一样向他开枪。三人拦下一名附近的警察，解释了发生的事情，并跳上巡逻车去追踪枪手。没花多长时间。他们很快发现年轻人穿过米申大道，警官调转车头进行追捕。意识到自己被追捕，枪手跑向附近的酒店，消失在夜色中。警察用无线电呼叫支援，促使其他警察赶到现场。他们一起开始搜查酒店的庭院，手电筒的光束划破了黑暗。
Suddenly, a shot rang out from the direction of the hotel's wedding chapel. The shooter had fired at his own right temple with a .38 caliber pistol which lay nearby. A driver's licence identified the man as 24-year-old Wayne David Chandler. He was transferred to hospital but died hours later. Chandler's death was unwelcome news to the detectives fronting the swindle investigation. After learning what Chandler had done, he'd become a suspect in their case. Now they were unable to question him to determine whether he had any involvement at all. Meanwhile, in Ocean Beach, business had dried up after the double homicide, with locals and tourists alike fearing the shooter would return.
突然，从酒店婚礼小教堂的方向传出一声枪响。枪手用一把.38口径的手枪对着自己的右太阳穴开枪，手枪就躺在附近。驾照显示该男子是24岁的韦恩·大卫·钱德勒。他被送往医院，但几小时后死亡。钱德勒的死对负责斯温德尔谋杀案调查的侦探来说是个不受欢迎的消息。在得知钱德勒所做的事情后，他已经成为他们案子的嫌疑人。现在他们无法审问他以确定他是否完全参与其中。与此同时，在海洋海滩，双重谋杀案发生后生意一落千丈，当地人和游客都担心枪手会卷土重来。
Merchants offered a $700 reward for information leading to the arrest of the swindle's killer, hoping to speed up a conviction and to draw back crowds. But years passed, and the bounty went unclaimed. The evening of Sunday, October 30, 1966, two years after the murders of Johnny and Joyce Swindle in Riverside, California. 18-year-old Sherry Jo Bates grabbed a pen and paper and scribbled a quick message. Dad went to RCC Library. She placed the note where her father would see it when he returned home from his trip to the beach. Sherry Jo then left home in her most prized possession, her lime green 1960 Volkswagen Beetle. The first-year Riverside City College student had taken great pride in the fact that she'd managed to buy the little car all by herself, with money saved from a part-time job. Shortly after 6pm, Sherry Jo arrived at the RCC Library alone, leaving her beloved Volkswagen parked 30 yards down the road on Terracina Drive.
商家悬赏700美元征集线索，以协助逮捕斯温德尔案的凶手，希望加速定罪并吸引人群回流。但几年过去了，这笔赏金无人认领。1966年10月30日星期日晚上，加利福尼亚州里弗赛德市的约翰尼和乔伊斯·斯温德尔夫妇被害两年后。18岁的谢莉·乔·贝茨抓起纸笔，快速写了一条留言。爸爸去RCC图书馆了。她把便条放在父亲从海滩回家时一眼就能看到的地方。随后，谢莉·乔开着她最珍贵的财产——她的青柠绿1960年大众甲壳虫汽车离开了家。这位里弗赛德城市学院的大一新生为自己用兼职工作攒下的钱独自买下这辆小车而感到非常自豪。傍晚6点刚过，谢莉·乔独自一人抵达RCC图书馆，将她心爱的大众汽车停在30码外的特拉西纳大道上。
Young and beautiful were the words that came to mind as he watched the petite co-ed with dark blonde hair and striking green eyes walk towards the library building. Once she was out of sight, he turned his attention to her car, a lime green Volkswagen Beetle. Working swiftly under the cover of darkness, he opened the Volkswagen's rear compartment where its engine was located. He removed the distributor coil and condenser, then took hold of the distributor's middle wire and tore it out before lowering the trunk shut and slinking away. He then made his way to the library, where he spotted the Volkswagen's owner studying alone. He watched and waited until she stood from the desk, collected her books, and headed outside. He let two minutes pass before taking off after her. Sherry Jo Bates climbed into the driver's seat of her Volkswagen.
当他看着这位身材娇小、留着深金色头发、有着一双醒目绿眼睛的女大学生走向图书馆大楼时，脑海中浮现出年轻美貌这个词。她消失在视线中后，他将注意力转向了她的车——一辆青柠绿色的大众甲壳虫。他借着夜色的掩护迅速行动，打开大众汽车发动机所在后备箱。他取下分电器线圈和冷凝器，然后抓住分电器的中间电线将其扯断，接着关上后备箱悄然离开。随后他走到图书馆，发现大众汽车的主人正在独自学习。他看着并等待着她从书桌旁站起来，收拾好书本，然后朝外走去。他等了两分钟才动身追了上去。谢莉·乔·贝茨爬进了大众汽车的驾驶座。
Tossing her pocketbook and the three library books she'd borrowed onto the passenger seat, she then inserted her keys into the ignition and turned them. Nothing happened. She tried again. Still nothing. For some unknown reason, her car wouldn't start. Suddenly, a man appeared at Sherry Jo's window. Acknowledging her car troubles, he offered to help. He said that his car was down the street and he'd be happy to give her a lift. Sherry Jo accepted the kind offer and followed the man as he headed away from the library. They soon reached a gravel alleyway between two houses that led to a car park.
她将手提包和借来的三本图书馆书籍扔在副驾驶座上，然后将钥匙插入点火孔并转动。什么也没发生。她又试了一次。还是什么都没有。由于某种未知的原因，她的车无法启动。突然，一个男人出现在谢莉·乔的车窗旁。他注意到了她的车况并主动提出帮忙。他说他的车就在这条街的尽头，很乐意载她一程。谢莉·乔接受了好意，跟着那个男人离开图书馆。他们很快到达了两栋房子之间通往停车场的一条砂砾小巷。
As the man guided Sherry Jo down the dark and quiet alley, he abruptly remarked, It's about time. Confused, Sherry Jo asked. About time for what? The man turned to her. About time for you to die. He launched at Sherry Jo and pressed one hand over her mouth while holding a small knife to her neck with the other. Sherry Jo fought back and the pair fell to the ground mid-struggle.
当男子引导谢莉·乔走过黑暗寂静的小巷时，他突然说道：“时候到了。”困惑的谢莉·乔问：“什么时辰到了？”男子转向她：“是你死的时候到了。”他扑向谢莉·乔，一只手捂住她的嘴，另一只手拿一把小刀抵住她的脖子。谢莉·乔奋起反抗，两人在争斗中摔倒在地。
She scratched at his face and tore at his hair. Sherry Jo managed to let out a desperate scream before he kicked her in the head to silence her. He then plunged his knife into her chest over and over, causing it to break before finally cutting her throat. I am not sick, he told himself. I am insane. Cleophus Martin was used to rising early for work. He was employed by Riverside City College as a groundskeeper and it wasn't unusual for him to begin his shift at the Crack of Dawn. When Cleophus arrived at the college in the early hours of Monday, October 31, the area was deserted.
她抓他的脸，扯他的头发。在被他踢中头部消音之前，谢莉·乔拼死发出了一声尖叫。随后，他将刀一次又一次地刺入她的胸膛，导致刀断裂，最后割断了她的喉咙。“我没病，”他对自己说，“我疯了。”克莱福斯·马丁习惯早起工作。他受雇于里弗赛德城市学院担任园丁，清晨开始轮班对他来说并不罕见。当克莱福斯在10月31日星期一清晨抵达学院时，该地区空无一人。
By around 6.30 he was driving his street sweeper along Teresina Drive on the north side of the campus library. Cleophus approached the alley that led to the student parking area. It ran between two large, vacant houses honed by the college. He glanced down the alley and caught sight of something bundled up on the ground towards the rear of the houses. It was a young woman lying face down in the dirt. Beneath her torso was a pool of blood. Police arrived at the scene and examined the woman. She was fully dressed in red Capri pants, a yellow blouse and white sandals.
大约6点30分，他驾驶着清扫车沿着校园图书馆北侧的特雷西纳大道行驶。克莱福斯走近通往学生停车场的小巷。它穿过两栋由学院所有的、大型且空置的房子。他朝小巷里瞥了一眼，发现在房屋后部附近的地上一堆鼓起的东西。那是一个年轻女子脸朝下趴在泥土里。她的躯干下方有一滩血迹。警察赶到现场对女子进行了检查。她身穿红色的七分裤、黄色衬衫和白色凉鞋。
Dry leaves were tangled in her dishevelled dark blonde hair. Her body had been stabbed with a small knife upwards of 42 times with lacerations found on her face, hands, arms, chest and back. The most violent wound was to her neck which had been so viciously cut that she was almost decapitated. There was no sign of sexual assault. Pressed beneath her was a straw tote bag. Papers inside featured the name Sherry Jo Bates. Scuff marks in the gravel indicated that Sherry Jo had tried to flee while foreign skin scrapings underneath her fingernails proved she had put up a fight. There were also four blood-soaked sandy brown hairs stuck to her right thumb.
干枯的树叶纠缠在她凌乱的深金色头发中。她的尸体被一把小刀刺了42次以上，面部、手部、手臂、胸部和背部都有裂伤。最致命的伤在她的脖子上，被残忍地割开，几乎被斩首。没有性侵的迹象。压在她身下的是一个草编手提袋。里面的文件上写着“谢莉·乔·贝茨”的名字。砾石上的擦痕表明谢莉·乔曾试图逃跑，而她指甲底下的外来皮肤碎屑证明她进行过反抗。她的右拇指上还粘着四根浸透鲜血的沙棕色头发。
Forensic testing limitations meant that only one key feature about the hairs could be ascertained. They had come from a white male. One student reported seeing a man standing in the shadows of the alley where Sherry Jo's body was later found. He was smoking a cigarette and staring fixedly at a lime green Volkswagen parked nearby. The student had managed to take in some of his features estimating his age to be 19 or 20 and his height about 5 foot 11. She'd exchanged a brief greeting with him before continuing on her way. Sherry Jo's unlocked Volkswagen was found on nearby Teresina Drive with the keys still in the ignition. Her pocketbook and textbooks remained on the passenger seat.
由于法医检测的局限性，关于这些头发只能确定一个关键特征。它们来自一名白人男性。一名学生报告说，看到一名男子站在小巷的阴影里，谢莉·乔的尸体后来就在那里被发现。他正在抽烟，直勾勾地盯着附近停着的一辆青柠绿色大众汽车。这名学生设法记住了他的一些特征，估计他的年龄在19或20岁左右，身高约5英尺11英寸。她与他短暂地互相问候，然后继续前行。谢莉·乔未锁的大众汽车被发现在附近的特雷西纳大道上，钥匙还插在点火开关里。她的手提包和教科书仍然留在副驾驶座上。
Examination of the car's engine revealed it had been tampered with, which prevented it from starting. Several foreign finger and palm prints were lifted from the driver's side front door, but the fingerprints weren't substantial enough to be analyzed. The three partial palm prints were in better condition, but weren't a match to anyone on file. Investigators believed that Sherry Jo remained in the library until it closed at around 9pm and was then lured from her car to the alleyway 100 yards away. As she was afraid of the dark and prioritized safety, some suspected Sherry Jo must have known her killer to have willingly gone with him. But the fact she'd left her precious car unlocked with the window down and the keys in the ignition implied she might have been forced to leave under duress. Resting on the ground 10 feet from Sherry Jo's body was a man's Timex brand wristwatch with a white stainless steel face. One of the fasteners had been torn off, leading detectives to speculate that Sherry Jo might have ripped the watch from her assailant during the attack.
对汽车发动机的检查显示它曾被人动过手脚，导致无法启动。驾驶员侧前门提取到了几个外来指纹和掌纹，但指纹不够清晰，无法进行分析。三个部分掌纹状况较好，但与存档的任何人都不匹配。调查人员认为，谢莉·乔在图书馆一直待到晚上9点左右闭馆，然后被诱骗离开汽车，走到100码外的小巷。由于她怕黑且把安全放在第一位，一些人怀疑谢莉·乔一定认识凶手，才会自愿跟他走。但她将宝贵的主驾驶车窗摇下、钥匙插在点火开关上且未锁车的事实暗示，她可能是被迫在胁迫下离开的。距离谢莉·乔尸体10英尺远的地上放着一块男士Timex（天美时）品牌手表，表盘为白色不锈钢。其中一个固定扣已经断裂，这让侦探们推测谢莉·乔可能在袭击过程中从袭击者手上扯下了这块手表。
Small flecks of white paint dotted its wristband. As the college was undergoing renovations at the time, some theorized that the watch could have belonged to someone connected to the campus. Timex watches were commonplace and there was no serial number on this one to trace its origin. The same model was sold at retail stores on US military bases both throughout the country and overseas. Some connected the paint and military link to Johnny Swindle who had been gunned down with his wife Joyce two years prior. Johnny, a naval man who had taken up painting to make Anne's meat, was robbed as he lay dying. If the watch was indeed Johnny's, this implied that Sherry Jo was a victim of the same killer. The Swindle's unknown, quote, psychopathic thrill killer was also thought to be responsible for the shooting murders of Robert Dominguez and Linda Redwoods.
其表带上点缀着白色的油漆小斑点。由于当时学院正在进行翻修，一些人推测这块手表可能属于与校园有关的人。天美时手表很常见，这块手表上也没有序列号来追溯其来源。同款手表在该国境内及海外美军基地的零售店都有售。一些人将油漆和军事联系联系到约翰尼·斯温德尔身上，他和妻子乔伊斯在两年前被枪杀。约翰尼是一名海军人员，为了补贴家用而开始画画，他在临死时遭到抢劫。如果这块手表确实是约翰尼的，这意味着谢莉·乔是同一个凶手的受害者。斯温德尔夫妇未知的、所谓的“精神病狂热杀手”也被认为应对罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·雷德伍德的枪击谋杀案负责。
While there were notable differences across each case, the similarities were striking enough to make some speculate that a serial killer was targeting Southern California's youth. Sherry Jo's murder stood out for seeming so wildly distinct but a deeper examination of the case uncovered hints of the familiar pattern. A young victim, a knife, a city with a water-based name, lack of a motive or suspects and the randomness of the attack. The watch wasn't the only military link uncovered at the bait crime scene. Pressed into the soil near Sherry Jo's body was the hill-print of a man's shoe, size 8 to 10. It had a distinctive waffle design unique to a type of shoe sold only to federal prisons and the military. The March Air Reserve Base was only 15 miles southeast of Riverside and 154 servicemen stationed there attended classes at RCC. All of these men were questioned in relation to the murder. None were charged.
虽然每起案件之间存在显着的差异，但相似之处惊人地相似，足以让一些人猜测连环杀手正在将目标锁定在南加州的年轻人身上。谢莉·乔的谋杀案因看起来如此截然不同而引人注目，但对案件的更深入检查发现了一些熟悉模式的蛛丝马迹。年轻的受害者、一把刀、一个以水命名的城市、缺乏动机或嫌疑人以及袭击的随机性。这块手表并不是在贝茨犯罪现场发现的唯一的军事联系。压在谢莉·乔尸体附近泥土里的，是一个男人的鞋跟印，尺码为8到10码。它具有一种独特的华夫饼设计，这种鞋只在联邦监狱和军队中销售。马奇空军预备役基地距离里弗赛德东南仅15英里，驻扎在那里的154名现役军人曾在RCC上过课。所有这些人都因谋杀案受到讯问。无人被起诉。
While detectives fronting the investigation considered the possibility that Sherry Jo's killer was a current or former serviceman, they couldn't rule out that the watch and shoes were red herrings. The killer might have intentionally staged this evidence to throw them off or perhaps the shoe print and watch were already in the alley long before the murder, making them entirely unrelated. The same could be said about a cigarette butt found near Sherry Jo's body. As night fell on November 13, 1966, the RCC library and its surroundings were a buzz. It had been two weeks since Sherry Jo Bates was murdered and the investigation had stalled. In an effort to generate leads, police had organized a full reenactment of the events leading up to the attack. 65 people who were known to have been at the library that evening agreed to participate. The males among them also provided hair and fingerprint samples to be tested against those recovered from the crime scene. None were a match.
虽然负责调查的侦探考虑了谢莉·乔的凶手是现役或退伍军人的可能性，但他们不能排除手表和鞋子是烟雾弹的可能性。凶手可能是故意安排这些证据来转移他们的视线，或者鞋印和手表早在谋杀案发生之前就已经在小巷里了，使得它们完全无关。关于在谢莉·乔尸体附近发现的烟头也可以这么说。随着1966年11月13日夜幕降临，RCC图书馆及其周边地区一片喧嚣。谢莉·乔·贝茨被谋杀已经过去两周，调查陷入停滞。为了收集线索，警方组织了一场对袭击前发生事件的完整重演。65名已知当晚在图书馆的人同意参与。其中的男性还提供了头发和指纹样本，以便与犯罪现场提取的样本进行比对。没有一个是匹配的。
Participants parked their cars in the same spots they had used two weeks earlier. Notably, some vehicles were missing. These included a bronze-colored 1965-1966 Oldsmobile that was seen following Sherry Jo's Volkswagen when she drove towards the library. A 1947-1952 model Studebaker that had parked south of Terrasiner Avenue an hour after Sherry Jo arrived. And a 1948 Tucker torpedo that parked directly behind Sherry Jo's Volkswagen. An older model vehicle was also heard starting up and driving away from the crime scene at the time of the attack. As some of these vehicles had similar design characteristics, police considered the possibility that they were all one car, mistaken as several. At 6pm, the library doors opened. Staff and students gathered inside as they had two weeks prior. Each person was dressed in the same clothing they'd been wearing on the night and everyone sat in the same seats.
参与者将他们的车停在两周前使用过的同一地点。值得注意的是，有些车辆不见了。其中包括一辆古铜色1965-1966年奥兹莫比尔，当谢莉·乔开车前往图书馆时，它被看到尾随谢莉·乔的大众汽车。一辆1947-1952年款的斯蒂庞克汽车，在谢莉·乔到达一小时后停在特拉西纳大道以南。以及一辆1948年的塔克鱼雷车，直接停在谢莉·乔的大众汽车后面。袭击发生时，还听到一辆旧款汽车启动并驶离犯罪现场。由于其中一些车辆具有相似的设计特征，警方考虑了它们其实是同一辆车、被误认为几辆车的可能性。下午6点，图书馆大门打开。工作人员和学生像两周前一样聚集在里面。每个人都穿着当晚穿的同一件衣服，每个人都坐在同一个座位上。
This time, the mood inside the cramped annex was somber and suspicious. There were few recollections of Sherry Jo who appeared to have come and gone mostly unnoticed. But soon, those present realized that one particular individual was missing. There had been a heavyset man with a beard in the library on October 30. He hadn't shown up for the re-enactment. On November 29, one month after Sherry Jo's murder, an employee of the Riverside City Police Department arrived at the local post office. Tasked with picking up the station's mail, they opened the police collection box and found an envelope inside. It was addressed to the Homicide Squad using thick handwritten block letters.
这一次，狭小附楼内的气氛阴郁而充满猜疑。对谢莉·乔的记忆很少，她似乎基本上是默默无闻地来去匆匆。但很快，在场的人意识到一个特定的人不见了。10月30日，图书馆里曾有一个身材魁梧、留着胡子的男人。他没有出现参加重演。11月29日，在谢莉·乔遇害一个月后，里弗赛德市警察局的一名员工来到了当地邮局。他们的任务是领取车站的邮件，他们打开了警方的收集箱，在里面发现了一个信封。信封是寄给凶杀组的，上面写着厚厚的手写印刷体大写字母。
There was no stamp. Upon opening the envelope, the employee found a white sheet of paper approximately 8 inches wide with the top and bottom portions torn off. Typed using a typewriter, the letter was written in capital letters and riddled with spelling and grammar errors. An identical letter was also sent to the office of the Riverside Daily Enterprise, addressed to the newspaper's crime reporters. It was titled A Confession, followed by the word by and a long blank space. The letter began. She was young and beautiful, but now she is battered and dead. She is not the first and she will not be the last.
没有邮票。打开信封后，这名员工发现了一张大约8英寸宽的白纸，顶部和底部都被撕掉了。这封信是用打字机打出来的，全部是大写字母，并且充斥着拼写和语法错误。一封一封相同的信也被寄到了《里弗赛德每日企业报》办公室，收信人是该报的犯罪记者。信的标题是《一份自白》，后面跟着“由”字和一个长长的空白。信的开始是这样的：“她年轻而美丽，但现在她饱受摧残，已经死去。她不是第一个，也不会是最后一个。”
I lay awake nights thinking about my next victim. Maybe she will be the beautiful blonde that babysits near the little store and walks down the dark alley each evening, about seven. Or maybe she will be the shapely blue-eyed brunette that said no when I asked her for a date in high school. But maybe it will not be either. But I shall cut off her female parts and deposit them for the whole city to see, so don't make it easy for me. Keep your sisters, daughters and wives off the streets and alleys. The author then claimed responsibility for the murder of Sherry Jo Bates, going into detail about how he had lured the 18-year-old to her death after disabling her car and offering her a lift. Miss Bates was stupid, he had written.
我夜不能寐地想着我的下一个受害者。也许她会是那个在小商店附近做临时保姆、每天傍晚七点左右走过黑暗小巷的漂亮金发女郎。或者她会是那个身材匀称、蓝色眼睛的黑发女郎，当年我在高中约她时，她拒绝了我。但也许两者都不是。不过我会割掉她的女性器官，将它们展示给整个城市看，所以别让我轻易得手。让你们的姐妹、女儿和妻子远离街道和小巷。”随后，作者声称对谢莉·乔·贝茨的谋杀案负责，并详细描述了他是如何在汽车抛锚并主动提出搭便车后，将这位18岁的女孩诱骗至死。“贝茨小姐太蠢了，”他写道。
She went to the slaughter like a lamb. He described the murder, his thought process and the dialogue between him and Sherry Jo step by step, including how he had told her that it was time for her to die. Claiming that he'd had a ball, he also offered a possible motive. Quote, only one thing was on my mind, making her pay for the brush-offs she had given me during the years prior. He concluded the letter with the following threat. I am not sick, I am insane, but that will not stop the game. This letter should be published for all to read it, it just might save that girl in the alley, but that's up to you. It will be on your conscience, not mine.
她像一只羔羊一样走向屠宰场。”他一步一步地描述了谋杀过程、他的心路历程以及他与谢莉·乔之间的对话，包括他是如何告诉她“是时候去死了”的。他声称自己“玩得很开心”，并提供了一个可能的动机。“引用：我脑子里只有一件事，让她为前几年给我的冷落付出代价。”他在信的结尾发出了以下威胁：“我没病，我疯了，但这不会阻止这场游戏。这封信应该公开发布供所有人阅读，它可能救了巷子里的那个女孩，但这取决于你。这会压在你的良心上，而不是我的。”
Yes, I did make that call to you also, it was just a warning. Beware, I am stalking your girls now. While investigators couldn't rule out the possibility that the letter was a hoax, the author's accurate description of undisclosed details led them to believe it was genuine. His claim that Sherry Jo rejected him indicated the pair had known each other. Yet, all of those closest to Sherry Jo had been ruled out, including her boyfriend who was 400 miles away in San Francisco when she was killed. The author calling himself insane was considered another clue. There was a mental health facility located on the same road as Riverside City College, and one patient had claimed to have committed the killing during the initial investigation. However, he was prone to delusions and his confession wasn't credible.
是的，我也给你打了那个电话，那只是一个警告。小心，我现在正在跟踪你们的女孩。”虽然调查人员无法排除这封信是个恶作剧的可能性，但作者对未公开细节的准确描述让他们相信它是真实的。他声称谢莉·乔拒绝了他，这表明两人互相认识。然而，所有与谢莉·乔最亲近的人都被排除在外，包括在她遇害时远在400英里外旧金山的男友。作者自称精神错乱被认为是另一个线索。里弗赛德城市学院同一条路上有一家精神健康机构，在最初的调查中，曾有一名病人声称自己犯下了谋杀案。然而，他容易产生妄想，他的自白不可信。
Investigators wondered whether the phrase, it's about time, referred to the Timex watch recovered from the crime scene. The mention of a phone call was more ambiguous, as no one recalled any suspicious calls recently received by the police department or newspaper. It was possible a call had come through and been dismissed as a crank, then quickly forgotten. In any case, the reference suggested the author was prone to phoning the authorities and the media to discuss his crimes. This behavior, coupled with the author's request that his letter be published for all to read, revealed that he wasn't confessing out of a desire to clear his conscience. He sought notoriety. On the night of Wednesday, December 7, just over a month after Sherry Joe Bates' murder, 19-year-old Linda Gillinger sat frozen in fear. She had just gotten behind the wheel of her car when she was startled by a stranger's voice.
调查人员想知道“是时候了”这句话是否指的是从犯罪现场找回的Timex手表。关于电话的提及则更加模棱两可，因为没有人记得警察局或报社最近接到过任何可疑电话。有可能曾有电话打进来，但被当作恶作剧挂断，随后很快被遗忘。无论如何，这个提及表明作者倾向于致电当局和媒体来谈论他的罪行。这种行为，加上作者要求公开发布他的信件供所有人阅读，表明他坦白并非出于洗清良心的愿望。他追求的是恶名。11月7日星期三晚上，也就是谢莉·乔·贝茨遇害一个多月后，19岁的琳达·吉林格吓得僵住了。她刚坐进汽车驾驶座，就被一个陌生人的声音吓了一跳。
A young man had broken into her vehicle and hidden in the back seat, awaiting her arrival. Linda didn't recognize him. He looked to be college-aged with short brown hair and a medium build. He ordered her to drive him to San Diego, just under a two-hour drive from Riverside. Linda couldn't refuse. The man was pointing a gun at her. Once they'd reached the destination, Linda's captor tried to kiss her. She forced him away with a swift slap to the face. He slapped her back, then barked at her to get out of the car. Locking the vehicle before throwing away the keys, he turned to Linda and remarked, Now you have as good a chance as I do.
一个年轻人闯入她的车并躲在后座，等待她的到来。琳达不认识他。他看起来像是大学生年龄，留着短棕色头发，中等身材。他命令她开车送他去圣地亚哥，距离里弗赛德不到两个小时的车程。琳达无法拒绝。那个人用枪指着她。一旦到达目的地，琳达的绑架者试图亲吻她。她狠狠地扇了他一巴掌，把他推开。他回扇了她一巴掌，然后粗暴地叫她下车。锁上车并扔掉钥匙后，他转向琳达并评论道：“现在你和我一样有同等的机会了。”
Linda ran away as fast and as far as she could. It was around 2am when she finally reached the San Diego Police Department to report her ordeal. Word of the hijacking reached detectives investigating Sherry Joe Bates' murder. They found themselves pondering whether Linda Gillinger had crossed paths with the co-ed's killer and inadvertently facilitated his escape. That same month, a janitor entered the Riverside City College Library's storage room and began stacking some plywood desks. As they went to lift one, they noticed someone had scrawled what appeared to be a poem on its underside. Measuring just under five and a half inches in length, it had been scratched into the desk in neat vertical rows, then gone over with a blue ballpoint pen. At the top was written, Sick of living, unwilling to die.
琳达尽可能快、尽可能远地逃跑了。大约凌晨2点，她终于到达圣地亚哥警察局报告了她的遭遇。劫持事件的消息传到了调查谢莉·乔·贝茨谋杀案的侦探耳中。他们发现自己开始琢磨琳达·吉林格是否与这位女大学生的凶手擦肩而过，并且无意中促成了他的逃跑。同月，一名清洁工进入里弗赛德城市学院图书馆的储藏室，开始堆叠一些胶合板桌子。当他们去搬起其中一张时，他们注意到有人在桌子底部乱画了类似诗歌的东西。长度不到五英寸半，是用蓝色圆珠笔在桌子上以整齐的垂直行刻上去的。顶部写着：“厌倦了活着，不愿死去。”
The rest read, Cut, Clean, If read, Clean, Blood spurting, Dripping, Spilling, All over her new dress. Oh well, it was read anyway. Life draining into an uncertain death, she won't die, this time someone will find her. Just wait till next time. Troubled by the message, the janitor notified the police and the desk was taken into evidence. While it couldn't be determined when the poem was written or what it was in reference to, speculation arose that it was written by Sherry Joe Bates' killer. Written in lower case at the end of the poem were the letters R-H. These were given many different interpretations. Some believed the letters indicated the initials of the RCC president, R-H Bradshaw.
其余内容写道：“切开，清洗，如果读了，清洗，鲜血喷涌，滴落，洒落，溅满她崭新的连衣裙。哦好吧，反正已经被读了。生命流向未知的死亡，她不会死，这次会有人发现她的。等着下一次吧。”清洁工对这条信息感到不安，便通知了警方，桌子作为物证被带走。虽然无法确定这首诗是何时写的或者它是指什么的，但有猜测认为它是谢莉·乔·贝茨的凶手写的。诗的结尾用小写字母写着“R-H”两个字母。这些有许多不同的解释。一些人认为这些字母代表RCC校长R-H布拉德肖的缩写。
While others thought they could stand for Riverside Halloween, the date Sherry Joe's body was discovered. Although police confiscated the surface of the desk, they weren't convinced it was relevant to the Bates case. The woman in the poem was described as wearing a red dress, whereas Sherry Joe was wearing pants and a blouse when she was killed. They were inclined to think the disturbing message was nothing more than a sick hoax. Four months later, an envelope arrived at the Bates household. It was addressed to Sherry Joe's father, Joseph, and postmarked April 30. Joseph opened the envelope and pulled out a lined piece of notebook paper. Scrawled across it in haphazard writing were the words,
而另一些人则认为它们代表里弗赛德万圣节，即谢莉·乔的尸体被发现的日期。尽管警方没收了桌子表面，但他们并不确信它与贝茨案有关。诗中的女子被描述为穿着红裙子，而谢莉·乔遇害时穿着裤子和衬衫。他们倾向于认为这则令人不安的信息不过是一个恶劣的恶作剧。四个月后，一个信封送到了贝茨家。收件人是谢莉·乔的父亲约瑟夫，邮戳日期为4月30日。约瑟夫打开信封，抽出一张带横线的笔记本纸。上面歪歪扭扭地写着这样的话：
she had to die, there will be more. That same day, near identical notes arrived at the Riverside Police Department and the Riverside Press Enterprise. In these versions, the pronoun she was replaced with the name Bates. Whoever wrote the letters hadn't left anything to identify themselves. They simply signed off each note with a squiggle that somewhat resembled the letter Z. To be continued next week. . There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她必须死，还会有更多。同一天，几乎相同的字条送达了里弗赛德警察局和里弗赛德新闻企业报。在这些版本中，代词“她”被名字“贝茨”所取代。写这些信的人没有留下任何可以识别他们身份的东西。他们只是在每张便条的结尾签上了一个有点像字母Z的波浪线。下周未完待续。。本集目前尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。